[Music]
hey what's up Samuel Leeds and today is
a day that I've just bought a brand new
Range Rover so I'm gonna I'm here at
Land Rover garage and I'm trying to find
it I'm a little bit early but they've
told me that it is now ready for
collection so let's have a walk around
let's see if we can find this bad boy
[Music]
hyah
alright ok it's not this one this one's
the sport it looks a little bit like
this one the same colors definitely not
this one
my wife has got the Discovery sport I
don't think it's any of these they all
look nice
they all look nice I like the sport it
looks pretty good in grey but I think
mine's gonna look better just to find it
where is it I think I've seen it I think
it's that big beautiful one up there in
the show room good day I hope this is
the one I think it is
[Music]
this is the one oh wow it's like taller
than me that is insane
oh man don't do this I need to find Jack
Jack I do man it's good to see ya
I hope my hope that the car in the
showroom is the one right yeah and this
was this was the show the showroom car
right it was I was gonna pay so this was
gonna be the showroom car this was gonna
be more than they put on display but I
liked it so much I just bought the
showroom once it was gonna be at one of
the bigger branches is gonna be the
showroom piece gonna be a centerpiece
and then mr. Leeds went ahead and bought
it and got some custom work done to it
so a couple questions I've got number
one is does it have a TV inside yes
does it have does it massage you yeah
does it park itself yourself yes all
right I think I think it's gonna be the
one is the oh I fire inside man it's
very very high up is Rick
[Music]
in the center console here for you
Samuel lift this up so you first of all
you buy you're connected between the
USBs but then in here you don't your
fridge order come pop no I will keep
order your drinks ice cold fresh
throughout your journey
how'd you watch TV saw TV you go onto
the multimedia player you got source
television I can watch the president
know Prime Minister yeah
mate I love it thank you so much you're
the rightful non-other cough thanks man
I appreciate that
epic the man thank you so much okay I
appreciate that I appreciate that
[Music]
[Music]
I've actually been in property for over
10 years and this is the first luxury
car that I've ever bought and I think
sometimes you need to wait it's called
delayed gratification you know wait
until you're at a position where you can
do it comfortably without having to
stretch so you know I've actually very
recently bought two things I've bought
this car and I also bought that house
and believe it or not this house cost a
lot lot less than this car but in order
to buy one of these you got to first buy
a whole lot of these
[Music]